listen now i'm going to get to the
question that i've just been dying to
ask
and you know apologies if it's uh
if it's rude but you create this
this platform called beam which was uh
sort of snapchat before snapchat
and uh you know and it kind of
went it evolved through like sort of
different kind of iterations of what it
was
um you sold it to cnn
for an estimated 25 million dollars
and then you referred to
its uh ultimate demise as taking an
l and my question is how the [ __ ] do you
sell a hot cake for 25 million bucks
and then that's an l
it was an l for a couple reasons it was
an x it wasn't a billion
okay it was an l because so much of my
team
like when when so what's first of all
let me just
let me give this podcast like a [ __ ]
you guys this is like an exclusive here
this is the first time someone's asked
me about
beam really since my nda expired
wow not that i'm sitting on any secrets
like an open book in fact like
it's so fun i can talk about this now
but like there were three different
occasions over the course of that four
year contract where like cnn called my
like people and they're like
yeah casey's talking about [ __ ] he's not
allowed to talk about and my agent would
have to call me like hey dude
you gotta shut the [ __ ] up and i'd be
like [ __ ] i'm sorry like i'm incapable
of
being open like i'm just like that's
just the kind of guy i am sure when did
your nba expire
i want to say it was four years four
years after the deal was signed so like
last may or something like that might
have been three years
but to answer your question like you
know i started a
tech company so i was really excited
about the idea of starting a tech
company and i think we had a great idea
for a product and you said snapchat
before snapchat
we were snapchat before snapchat but
then snapchat launched stories
and when they launched stories i was
like oh [ __ ] that's like what we're
building but
way better and they released it before
us
so like we were snapchat before snapchat
but we were also snapchat
later and we weren't tomorrow good
it's like look snapchat look snapchat
users i know you love your product and i
know it's great but we've got something
worse for you
just give us a few more months
just be patient right if you'll be
patient we'll get you something even
worse
um back now you'll play twice as much
exactly
no i think we like we had an amazing
team and we did have something that was
really compelling like the thesis of
that app was amazing it was like not
about filters it's just about sort of
sharing the real world around
you and i think a lot of people spoke to
that and i think since then
we've seen other apps be successful
because they represent some version of
that like people yearn for the
truth when everything is like [ __ ]
face shaping filters and stuff like you
just want some reality
so we had a great product and cnn's
enthusiasm i think was
naively i didn't realize how much it was
for my reach
and my success right you know like i
really pushed them hard and like the
original pitch
came because jeff zucker the cnn
boss who i think just recently stepped
down he was a great guy and a wonderful
experience with him but i met with him
and he's like
what do i have to do to get you to come
over to cnn and i was like nothing i
don't
there's nothing cnn has that i'm
interested in i love being on youtube
and i was like but your tech sucks like
your app sucks like your technology is
garbage um i was like you should buy my
tech company and we should build stuff
together and
that's where it came from and that's
what they bought they bought my tech
company they kept every employee on
and i was really excited about building
technology with them
and i think that ultimately like a big
company like that they've got like
shareholders and all kinds of [ __ ] that
as a nimble startup you don't have to
confront
they need to make money they have to
show how we're making money
so the kind of company that i like to
build which is like give us three years
to figure out exactly who we are and how
we're gonna make this work
was like no no no we need profits in six
months sort of thing like we need
revenue in six months
here's how we have to and it wasn't they
weren't wrong or unfair to
ask that or to expect that but i think
that it was a misalignment to take like
a really nimble
tech startup that has sort of the
mentality of of
entrepreneurs and founders in trying to
sort of force that round peg into the
square hole which is like a
you know whatever turner is a 50 year
old institution and that's where the
misalignment came from
and i think that they tried to save that
by
you know getting rid of my partner and i
after a year they fired matt and me
which was super amicable and the people
who did it did it right and it was a
great thing like everyone at cnn was
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] about it
but then they brought my whole team
internal and like i really
that for me was a big l because like
every single employee at beam
was hired because like i vouched for
that company and like i felt like in
some part they were all there because of
me
um so you're saying that they let you
and matt go but they sort of stole
your uh no almost the opposite like they
let us all
go and matt and i were really adamant
about like he can't
shut this you can't fire the team and
they're really forceful about the fact
we're keeping the whole team together
we're bringing everybody in
so so you were stroked on that sort of
what i wasn't soaked on like it was like
a it was like a
it was nice that everybody wasn't losing
their job it was shitty because
everybody signed up to work for a cool
ass startup
and now everybody literally has to check
in and go into this gigantic building
in midtown and work at cnn and then like
shortly thereafter like you know matt
and i
had no part of the company we weren't
like
really supposed to be interacting with
our former employees at
all but you know you start hearing
stories and people are unhappy and
people start leaving and then they broke
up this team
and this team's not working out and this
person could keep their job if they move
so they didn't keep their it just sort
of fell apart
and like the money the paycheck [ __ ]
yeah like big success i couldn't be more
excited about that
every founding member of the company
before the acquisition got
paid my personal assistant like a kid
who's like 22 out of college and like
his job was like make sure the studio
lights were always on and like deal with
admin [ __ ] like
he got like a the kind of check where
you could buy like a very decent house
and we made sure of that like everybody
vests a hundred percent
day one like we fought for the team but
in the end like i
really and i still to this day like
really feel like i let that team
down because like the success of that
company would have succeeded because of
me and its failure was
it failed because of me so i can i can
have a litany of excuses of why cnn made
it really hard to succeed
i think it's all [ __ ] in the end
like if i still should have been able to
figure out how to navigate that and find
success and i didn't
so in the end the l is the company
culture and like
sort of this exciting thing about
working for a tech startup just got lost
because now those people work
for cnn i think that's a nuanced way of
getting into i think the l
for me was about integrity like i didn't
feel like i could walk away with my head
high
just because i got a really dope
paycheck that's crazy because um
you know we were talking to mark cuban a
couple weeks ago
and his whole thing was uh
in the dot-com bubble he sold
his company to yahoo and like
right before the bubble burst he got
millions of dollars and then like almost
immediately after the transaction
what he sold for millions of dollars was
like completely worthless i think
he was closer to billions i think you're
right i think you're right i think it
might have actually been billion yeah
is it 300 million or something like that
yeah but it's it's it's uh
you know ever since then i think it's
it's you know
hailed as like the best business move
ever that mark cuban made the best
business move for him right
in unloading this this company before it
became totally worthless
and i think that that that's you know on
some level very comparable to what you
did with beam
because it never even really you know
like exploded in the first place
and like you were able to sell it for
like
arguably more than it was worth and and
you unloaded it and then it
kind of went away so like to me that's
just
like i think it all comes down to
what's the end game like what is how do
you define success and if the definition
of success is like
get the [ __ ] bag then mark cuban's
the most successful guy in the world if
the success if your definition of
success is something different from that
then it's you know then it's i think a
little bit more complicated and like my
definition of success for that company
was a little bit more than like you know
me getting that
cnn bag and like no regrets i'm very
proud of what we did
like like one of the things i never talk
about
is the fact that like when you're like
the ceo and you're like the founder you
raise all this money
you write like once a month once every
two months these updates all of your
investors
and they're formal and like truth be
told my partner matt
mostly wrote them and then sent them to
me and i would put them into my own
email and send them because i'm like
you know i can barely read and write
over here
i had a d minus in 10th grade english um
matt got college man that kid's smart
and and then like so you have to send
these monthly updates like here's what
we're up to here's where we're
struggling here's where we're succeed
i just stopped sending those because the
company was just doing so poorly this is
before cnn bought us we were doing we
were out of money we were just
[ __ ] users were dropping off and i
just stopped sending those
and when you stop getting those that
means the company's going tits up
and then six months later i got to i had
to call all the investors
every single investor on the list and i
was calling them to let them know
that we had sold the company and how big
their returns were
and that day to me like that is the
benchmark
of success all these people whether
they're just like
you know venture capitalists who are
only interested in return or they're
much more thoughtful people who are like
i believe in you casey and i want to
support you
they all looked at me and decided i
believe in this guy enough to write him
a check
and the fact that i was able to deliver
on that to every single person was a
huge deal
like to me yeah that is the that moment
was the ultimate success much more so
than the paycheck
so when you when i talk about like an l
at beam like
again i got that paycheck was great but
like if the paycheck had a fraction of
that
but like we had built something that to
this day is still thriving
and all those employees like went on to
bigger and better things or felt great
about what their contributions are
that would have like i'd sleep with a
bigger smile at night but how do you
know
the employees aren't thinking that right
now they might be but i know that like
in the year that in the years months
after we sold the company whether they
were working for us under cnn
or they were working directly at cnn
under a different boss that it wasn't
the same
level of enthusiasm and satisfaction
that it was working for a nimble startup
or
actually a part of something that that
is kind of your own that you have a kind
of ownership over
because they all had a bunch of bar
codes on their necks scott okay
sorry scott it's also it's also like in
that spit
space and i haven't had a i've been out
of the tech game for five years now but
like
then and i'm sure it's the same way now
like mobile app developers that can deal
in video
are the most sought after programmers
out there like they're they're so
exclusive we had to talk a lot of our
employees into moving to new york from
the west coast where they live
like every single one of them could have
left working for us on a monday
and gone and gotten 3x the paycheck on a
tuesday from
from facebook which was just 12 blocks
north from us
like they could every one of them could
have done that and every one of them
said no
i love this company i believe in these
guys i love matt i love casey
i want to be a part of what they're
building and like the fact that i wasn't
able to deliver on that like
that that sucks that sucks these are
people that are all [ __ ] smarter than
me and keep
more capable than me and that have like
built their careers out and like
that's part of their gamble too they
knew they were taking their chance
but like man what i have loved for those
every one of those people who took a
chance on me for me to be able to just
like
give them those kind of dividends i was
able to give those investors
do you have another startup in you i
don't
know i mean that's like a it's like a
much bigger conversation which is like
you know now i'm sort of confronted with
this fact that i'm 40 years old
and i've got money which is weird i'm
just like you know used to be on welfare
now i've got money
and like i don't need to work for money
right now
so therefore like where's the motivation
and if you like dig deep enough in
yourself
like where i've landed is like i can
either go work for money
or just like hang out with my
two-year-old so like
today she and i like played in the
garden and like tried not to prick our
fingers on roses and then we
ate like candy that was way more fun
than starting a company
so yeah so like that's kind of where i
am right now is like
i don't know when you're faced with a
question of like you can do whatever you
want today what do you want to do
every day for me is like i want to play
with my kids and go surfing
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude